Pete Davidson reveals who he cried to
after his broken engagement and this
might be the last time you hear ariana
grande talk about her love life
so it seems Ariana Grande is not
interested in having an ex-boyfriend
anytime soon we don't blame you girl on
New Year's Day Ari responded to a fan
speculating about her love life writing
spoiler for the rest of this year
probably my life it's no one please
refer back to this tweet for future
questions but shortly after her tweet
Ariana was spotted out on New Year's Day
with her ex Ricky Alvarez after swearing
off dating in 2019 I don't see Ari
staying single forever she's just been
through a lot and it's time for her to
enjoy some self-love we all need it
she's really got her together you know
like she's really on it like she's got
it all and I do but I as far as like my
personal life goes I really have no idea
what I'm doing
someone who isn't quite done discussing
his past Ari's ex Pete Davidson
the comedian got candid in a New Year's
Eve show in Boston about how he cried in
front of his mom after calling it quits
with Ariana in October Pete also poked
fun about how most pop stars don't name
their exes in songs I mean I can name a
few Robin Thicke Andre 3000 I mean the
list goes on but for 2018 thank you next
is definitely a bob so during the show
he reportedly joked not this wonderful
lady this diabolical genius named all of
us
something wish I could say thank you
[Music]
like I said ariana is a musical genius
writing a love note to her past romances
but the singer has been really open with
her fans as she mourns the loss of her
ex Mac Miller of course we know they
were together for two years and he had a
sad fatal overdose ariana shared a
tribute of his hands playing on a
keyboard but quickly deleted it without
an explanation
I think after Ariana's whirlwind 20:18
she doesn't need to explain herself
anymore in 2019 really happy to hear
Pete is in a better mental state I mean
here's to hoping comedy is his cure and
for all the latest in pop culture be
sure to subscribe to ET until next time
I've had Kourtney underscore teza know
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]